FUMI YAMAZAKI: OK.
Hello everyone.
Thank you for coming.
I'm super excited
that we're having Joel
Gurin the author of this book
"Open Data Now" to Google.
JOEL GURIN: OK.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
I want to say a couple of quick
things before we get started.
You can see on this slide I have
a website as well as a book.
The website is
also open data now,
just for the sake of simplicity.
I use @joelgurin
for Twitter I also
use the hash tag #opendatanow.
There is a pattern there.
I'm very happy to be
speaking to you today.
Also, if you didn't see it on
the way in, on the way out,
there is a sign
up sheet if you're
interested in getting free
email updates from my website
or from the GovLab.
Please sign up and
we'll keep in touch,
because there is a
lot to talk about.
So why open data and how did I
get into this particular area?
I have to start by saying I am
probably by a couple of orders
of magnitude the least technical
person in this room right now.
So what you're going
to hear from me--
and it is a little humbling,
to say the least, to come
to talk about data
to Google-- but what
I hope I can bring
to this is a sort
of sense of overall
perspective and context
from the work that I've done
in government and non-profits,
as a journalist and
now in academia.
I really have tried to get
us a sense and sort of paint
a picture of how open data
is being seen and used
in society today that I hope
will be helpful to all of you.
And I certainly hope we have
a little time for questions.
So my background very
briefly-- as Fumi told you,
I began as a science journalist.
I was editorial
director, and then
executive vice president
of "Consumer Reports" when
we launched
consumerreports.org, which
is the largest paid information
subscription site on the web
now with about 3 million
active paid subscribers.
Shortly after that, I went
to the Federal Communications
Commission, began as head
of the Consumer Bureau.
And at that point our
chairman, Julius Genachowski,
was very interested
in figuring out
how we can give consumers
help in a simple decision
like choosing a cellphone plan.
Well choosing a
cellphone plan ends up
being kind of like solving some
difficult problem in topology
or some such thing
or at least in
statistics, because there are
about 1,000 different cellphone
plans offered by a
company like Verizon.
You multiply that by
the number of companies,
you factor in the fact
that every consumer has
different needs, so it became
pretty clear as I was looking
at this and this is a problem
is more complicated than it
looks at first.
It also turns out to be
very similar to problems
that other government
agencies face
in trying to advise
consumers on things
like financial services,
housing, mortgages, education,
and so on.
So I began talking to
people in other agencies
about consumer
information, generally.
Out of that I was invited to
chair the White House Task
Force on Smart Disclosure.
Smart disclosure being
the term that we developed
to describe giving
data to consumers
that they can use to
make complex decisions.
That report came out last May.
And from that work I
became more involved
in open data and open
government more generally.
I met Beth Noveck,
who some of you
may know as the head of the
Open Government Initiative
during President Obama's
first term and a real pioneer
and open government
and open data.
She has now invited me to
come work at the GovLab
that she founded at NYU.
And I'll tell you a
few things about that.
And I also have this website
and this book on open data
now, so I am sort of
running the open data
practice for the
GovLab and looking
at the implications of
open data in many ways.
Just a couple words
about the GovLab.
I won't read what you
can see on the screen,
but our basic hypothesis
and our mission
is to figure out how to use
technology and collaborative
platforms and
basically 21st century
approaches to help improve
governance and government,
and the way that citizens
and government interact.
We think that people should
interact with government more
than when they vote
once a year or when
they happen to make a comment on
We the People petition website
or something like that.
We're looking at ways
to really develop
a different level
of engagement that
is good both for citizens
and for government as well.
And this model of
collaborative democracy we feel
has three major
modes of operation-
the first one is
sharing responsibility,
where a government can
take a piece of what
has been a government
responsibility
and delegate that to citizens.
And here the paradigm is
participatory budgeting,
where in 1,500 cities
around the world now
the city government is saying,
you take a chunk of the budget
and spend it as you wish.
We think that can be done in
many other kinds of governance
situations and that
would be very productive.
The second modality is getting
knowledge and expertise in.
Figuring out ways that not
just the traditional government
advisers, but people
with technical abilities,
technical skills, insight into
community issues, and so on,
can advise government at the
federal, state, and city level
and we're seeing a lot
of models for that.
And then the third modality
is getting open data out,
which is what I work on and what
I'm going to talk about today.
So what is open data?
There are a number
of good definitions
that have been done
by different groups
like the Open Knowledge
Foundation and the Sunlight
Foundation.
What I did in
writing this book was
to choose a fairly
general definition-
that open data is accessible
public data that people,
companies, and organizations
can use to launch new ventures,
analyze patterns and trends,
make data-driven decisions,
and solve complex problems.
This definition
incorporates not only
open data from government, which
is where a lot of the focus
has been, but also open data
from sources like social media.
For many sources that
are accessible to you
at Google, and from other
kinds of data that companies
themselves may choose to
release in different ways, as
well scientific data.
So what you're going to
hear me talk about today
is open data in
all of those forms
and how they relate
to each other,
and how they relate to
social and business goals.
I do think-- and I'm
certainly convinced having now
worked in this area
for a couple of years--
that we're talking
about a phenomenon that
has tremendous implications
and tremendous impact
potentially not only
for business, but also
for as for scientists,
for journalists,
for consumers, and
for government.
And in many ways,
we're starting to see
a convergence of the civic
and the commercial uses
of open data, where we're
seeing some ventures that
may start as non-profits that
turn out to have a sustainable
business model.
And we're seeing
businesses that turn out
to be actually
extremely mission driven
in their use of open data.
And you'll see many
examples today.
What is open data not?
Open data is not the
same as big data.
And it's not the same
as open government
and it's not even
really a blending
of big data and open government.
It's a different kind animal.
Big data also has
many definitions.
I think the only thing everybody
agrees on, at least when
I ask them, is that
when you're talking
about what you mean by big data,
we mean like really, really
a lot of data.
Really big data sets, which
is not too surprising.
I think you can more accurately
say that big data involves
data sets that are at the
current limit of our ability
to analyze and use,
but, of course, that
limit changes every day.
I do think there are real ways
in which the quantity of data
has a qualitative impact.
In the same way that when
I came here from New York,
I theoretically could
have ridden a bicycle,
or even walked,
and taking a plane
is really more than an
accelerated way of doing that,
it's a whole different
kind of travel.
So I think that big data does
have that kind of impact.
But it's not philosophically
different in my view anyway
from smaller data
problems in the way
that open data is
philosophically its own thing.
Open government is
very closely related
to the concept of open
data, but it's broader.
Open government
includes all kinds
of government transparency.
It also includes the kinds
of collaboration and things
that I just showed on
the GovLab's slide.
So part of it is data
related but part of it
is really other kinds
of citizen engagement.
So the book does present
the grand unified theory
of what is open data in
a simple Venn diagram
that you will find in
appendix A in the book,
and you can also
find on my website
opendatanow.com in a
fairly lengthy blog post.
I won't go through all
this to analyze it,
but the most important
thing to notice
here is that big data, open
data, and open government
have several points and
areas of intersection.
They are distinct,
but they overlap.
And when they overlap, it
gets really interesting.
The point in the middle,
sector six there,
which is all three
things-- these
are large public government
data sets like weather, GPS,
Securities and Exchange
Commission data center.
This is where we're going
to see some of the highest
economic value and some of the
highest potential civic value.
But it is by no means
the only thing that's
important about open data,
or the only kind of open data
that's important.
So that's the terrain.
Having said that, I'm going
to take you very quickly,
believe it or not, through what
I see as nine open data trends.
I'm going to pose
three open open data
questions that I don't
have the answers to,
but I think we can all probably
discuss and think about.
And I'm going to describe
a study that we're now
doing at the GovLab that I think
will be of interest you called
the Open Data 500, that I think
is going to really help advance
this field.
So let's get started.
So the first trend is
liberating government data.
It's undeniable that
governments at all levels
not only in the US,
but in countries
around the world are now
focusing on ways that they can
take data that they
control and make
it available to the
public as open data.
And in the US, we've seen
a major step forward.
Most recently last May,
when President Obama
announced the new
Open Data Policy.
This policy has been
called the biggest change
in how we deal with
federal information
since the Freedom of
Information Act the 1960s.
It's potentially that big.
There are a lot of questions
about how we implement it,
which I'll talk about.
But it is a very
ambitious and I think
a very right-thinking
kind of program
to make government
data open by default.
Meaning that unless there's
a security reason or privacy
reason or something like that
to keep it hidden, it's open
and anybody ought to use it.
Now one thing that's
really significant
is that when the president
announced this policy,
he used these words,
which you could see
are very business focused and
he actually chose a technology
center in Austin Texas to do it.
So the administration is
really positioning open data
as a job creator and
as a business driver.
That's partly why
we at the GovLab
are studying it
through that lens,
because we want to see to
what extent that is really
a defensible proposition.
I think it is, but I think
it's still a work in progress.
So the whole question
of why should government
go to the trouble
and the expense,
and the time of making data
open, part of the answer people
think, is that it's going
to have an economic benefit
as well as being a social good.
This Open Data Policy, which
was announced last May,
talks about presumption of
openness or open by default
making data machine
readable, reusable timely.
This was based in many ways
on the definitions of the Open
Knowledge Foundation and
the Sunlight Foundation
developed several years ago.
One really
interesting difference
is that those definitions said
and the data has got to be free
and the government definition
doesn't quite say that.
So there's still some room for
agencies to charge for data,
but I think the
direction is very
much towards free open data.
In addition to
this policy, there
is now something called
the DATA Act, which
may be the only thing
in the known universe
that Ralph Nader and Grover
Norquist actually agree on.
It is it's an extremely
bipartisan movement
it stands for Digital
Accountability and Transparency
act.
This is another
part of open data.
So one part of open data,
like the Open Data Policy,
is let's release data we have
on weather, satellite data,
GPS, health data, et cetera--
data that government collects
that is useful to the public.
This is data that
government has about itself.
The goal of the DATA Act is
to make government spending
data more thorough,
more transparent,
more usable than it's
ever been by a lot.
To be able to make it
go all the way down,
not just to the
contractors to government,
but subcontractors,
sub-subcontractors,
and to do it in a way
that is really accurate.
There is a website
called usaspending.gov.
It was intended to do this.
The Sunlight Foundation
recently calculated
that it is inaccurate to the
tune of $1.55 trillion a year.
Otherwise, it's perfect.
So the DATA Act would automate
this in a way that would really
solve that kind of
problem and there
is a lot of push now in Congress
to pass the DATA Act, which
I think would be another
major step forward.
So this is just at
the federal level,
but you're seeing similar
kinds of activity in cities,
in states, in the
60 countries that
now belong to the Open
Government Partnership.
All of which are making
similar kinds of commitments
to open data for both civic
and job-creating reasons.
That's one trend.
The next trend, which
comes right out of that,
is that we are actually
seeing open data begin
to drive business growth
in a number of ways.
And you can find examples
all over the place- health,
education, transportation.
My book has a
number of examples.
Somebody tweeted
recently, there's
so many apps and
businesses in here.
I can't even count them.
So I figured I would count them.
There are to the best of
my knowledge, 183 of them.
So, happy reading.
You will find companies
in all of these sectors
and they're doing some
very creative things
with open data that are
showing that you don't have
to own the data in
a proprietary way
to make a thriving
business out of it.
I'll just show you a
couple of examples.
So the Climate Corporation
based here in San Francisco
has become in many ways
sort of the poster child
for the commercial
use of open data.
I like to say I sort
of knew them when.
They've gotten a fair amount
of publicity over the years.
I was fortunate to have a long
interview with their CEO David
Friedburg last April.
It's in the book.
And there's actually a longer
podcast with him on my website.
And if you're really
interested in the stuff
I would encourage you to
check out the podcast,
because it's a
fascinating story.
And the punch line
is they were recently
bought by Monsanto
for a billion dollars.
They've been profiled
in "The New Yorker,"
so they've emerged as
everyone's favorite example,
and I think rightly so, of
what this kind of data can do.
Their story is fascinating.
They began by saying
that they wanted
to sell better
weather insurance.
And they quickly focused
on farming and farmers
as their target.
They figured that if they
could get all this data
from the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration,
from NASA weather
data, et cetera,
and they applied really
extremely smart analytics.
And the guy who started it
just hired brilliant people.
I think he actually
used to work at Google.
And I'm sure he hired
some people from here.
But what they
figured they could do
was do risk calculations
that would enable them
to use to calculate the risk
that they bore as an insurer
more accurately, so that
they could both help farmers
and also make a
business out of it.
Well what happened
as they got into this
is that they found that
there were open data
sources that they could
use that were much better
and that would give them a much
better result than the commonly
used sources.
So the first
iteration of this is,
let's use data from
weather stations.
Well if you're a
farmer, even if you
look at every weather
station the US,
it might be 30 miles
away from your farm
and it's not helpful to you.
So long story
short, they ended up
getting data so that they could
look at a piece of farmland
roughly the size of this
mid-sized auditorium or even
smaller.
They can calculate rainfall
to one hundredth of an inch.
They can look at
soil quality in a way
that they know exactly
how the soil is going
to respond to that
amount of rain.
And they're doing all of
this with almost all of it
with a couple of
small exceptions
is public open data that
anybody any one of us
theoretically could
access, but we
wouldn't know what
to do with it.
And knowing what to do with it
and knowing how to analyze it,
and bringing together both data
analysts, and subject matter
experts, to create
this new kind of tool
is how they have created a
billion dollars worth of value.
They also believe
that they can now
increase profitability for
farmers worldwide by 20% to 30%
and help farmers understand
how to deal with climate change
by changing the crops they grow
and the seasons in which they
grow them.
So this is huge.
This goes from we're
insurance salesmen to we're
leading the next
Green Revolution.
It's a direct application
of free open data
and it's a stunning
demonstration
of how even data that
is free and public
can be an incredibly
important business driver.
A lot of people
think health care
will be the next big frontier.
This is a picture Todd Park,
who was the Chief Technology
Officer for Health
and Human Services
and for the last
couple years has
been CTO for the United States.
He runs this event in
Washington every year
called The Health Datapalooza.
Datapalooza, as
somebody pointed out,
could be literally defined as
an all out crazy party of data
and that is pretty much
what these things are.
They get about
2,000 people a year.
And we are seeing
a lot of activity
in the health care center.
iTriage is an example that
uses the public registry
of health care providers.
So that if you're traveling
and you have some symptoms,
it can immediately tell you
for those symptoms are serious.
And if they are,
it'll tell you how
to get to the nearest
emergency room
very quickly, even if
you're in a strange city.
In finance we're seeing a lot
of companies like this one.
This is CapitalCube, which is
now owned by Analytics Insight.
There are about 40,000
publicly traded companies
in the world for which
there is enough information
to say anything
intelligent about them.
These guys figured
out algorithms
to analyze all 40,000 of
them update their information
every single day, put their
results into a prose form
that any investor can
read, provide graphs
that show the relative risk
and the expected return
for a given company compared
to its competitors, et cetera.
Again this is not actually
necessarily using a new data
source.
They're using SEC data that's
been available for a while,
but they're applying a level of
analytics that probably was not
possible before fairly recently.
This is becoming
and we're seeing
a lot of businesses in
the financial sector.
There's stuff
happening in energy.
Opower is a company that's
now working with utilities.
It will give you back not only
your own energy usage data,
but an aggregate summary of your
neighbors energy usage data,
which is apparently the
most powerful motivator
to clean up your own act is
the fact that you got to do
as well as your neighbors.
They're using this
together with a lot
of open data about energy
and energy usage and energy
efficiency to help
people save energy
and ultimately, hopefully
help fight climate change.
So there's many, many
examples but those just
give you a sense
of how this goes.
Now the interesting thing
in a segue from Opower
what they are
ultimately about is
helping consumers choose how
they're going to use energy.
So this gets back to what I told
you was the problem that got me
into this whole area
of the first place-
how do you choose
a cellphone plan?
Well this whole area of smart
disclosure is about open data.
It's almost like a sort
of subset of open data.
It's about figuring out
how to get data that's
going to be useful to average
people to improve their lives
and put it out there
in a usable form.
Who here has read "Nudge"
by Cass Sunstein and Richard
Thaler?
It's a great book
if you're at all
interested in
behavioral economics.
It's a perfect read and
it's also interesting,
because it inspired
a ton of work
in the Obama administration.
So it's very much
about how understanding
collective behavior
in psychology
can help you make
policy decisions.
It was actually tested during
the first Obama campaign.
One simple example is they
found that if they planted-- not
planted, that's too strong a
word-- if they promoted news
stories before every
state primary election
that there was going to
be huge voter turn out,
there would in fact
be huge voter turnout,
because nobody
wants to be left out
when there's going to
be huge voter turnout.
So it became a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy,
because they knew
that more voter
turnout would be
helpful to them.
Actually that may have been
in the election itself,
not the primaries--
correcting myself.
So anyway Cass Sunstein,
who was the regulatory czar
for the Obama administration,
is a big thinker in this area.
Richard Thaler,
who's an economist
at the University of
Chicago, is as well.
Their book "Nudge" was about how
you can create behavioral cues
and use information in ways that
nudge people to make choices
that are better for them.
Well, so here's an example- so
while Cass was regulatory czar,
one of the things that they
did is they reformed the label
that you see on cars
around energy efficiency.
And you can see very clearly
the most obvious change here.
So they go from the small type
saying, estimated fuel cost
2000 something a year to you
save $1,850 in fuel costs
over five years.
So it's a very simple example
but a pretty compelling one
of how the way you present
information affects what people
get from it and how
they make decisions.
OK that was very much the basis
of the Smart Disclosure Task
Force.
And what we set out to
do was to say, how do we
use these kinds of principles
at a time when most people are
getting information either on
their smartphones or on the web
and where we're really trying
to figure out how to give people
information that is
personalized to them?
So think about how Kayak works.
I mean this is a pretty
amazing tool that
allows you to go online and
choose the flight that you want
to take tomorrow to wherever
you want to go out of literally
thousands of flights and you
can do in about 10 minutes.
So the question
we start to ask is
what if there was a
Kayak for everything?
What would that look like?
There was a lot
of work now to try
to figure out, how do you do
this for financial services?
How do you do this for
health care insurance?
How do you do it for
mortgages, credit cards-- all
these decisions that
frankly drive most of us
completely nuts every day,
either that or you just sort
of pick one and
hope you're right.
Going back to cell phones
as the paradigm here,
it's been calculated that
Americans lose something
like $13 billion a
year collectively,
because we're not using most
efficient cellphone plans.
So this is real money and
in many cases of like health
insurance it's also safety,
and quality of care,
and quality of service.
So there have been a couple of
successful experiments here.
One of the ones I like a lot is
a site called greatschools.org.
This is a nonprofit.
They use state data.
They use state data to analyze
the quality of public schools
and help people
make those choices.
This thing is now
used by more than 40%
of all K through 12
households in the US,
which is just kind of fantastic
and shows you how much hunger
there is for this
kind of information.
Another success-- this one
is from the UK-- I always
like this because it's just
sort of so bizarre so this
is a site called
comparethemarket.com One night,
probably after a
couple of vodkas,
somebody must have
been kidding around.
They were trying
on Russian accents
and somebody said it's
like, comparethemeerkat.com.
Somebody then said, that
is a brilliant idea.
They decided that there are
a symbol should be a meerkat.
And there is now
the spokes-meerkat
in the UK called
Alexander Orlov, who
is the spokes-thing for
comparethemarket.com.
This thing became so
popular that Harrods
was going to-- yes,
you can collect
all six exclusive meerkat toys.
This is like a car
insurance shopping site.
This is like as
if the Geico gecko
was sextuplets or something.
I don't know what it's like.
But this thing became
so popular that they
were going to sell these one
year one Christmas at Harrods
and the CEO apparent
said we can't
do that there's going to
be a run on the store.
We're just going to give
them all to charity.
It has also made them a
very successful company.
Now what this shows-- beyond
the fact that people like fuzzy
stuffed animals
and that marketers
have bizarre, but successful
ideas-- what this shows
it is also possible to build
a successful business doing
comparisons of car insurance,
home insurance, life
insurance, energy, credit cards,
travel insurance, et cetera.
Nobody has yet made this model
really successful in the US,
but it is a huge consumer need.
And I think one of
the things that we're
going to see in the years
ahead is that smart disclosure
people are going to figure
out how to really do
smart disclosure the right way
and it'll be both the consumer
service and a successful
business model.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JOEL GURIN: Why hasn't
it made it in the US?
I think there is a
couple of reasons.
I think one is that
people haven't quite
found the right
business model yet
that will do it in an honest
way and yet also be successful.
A lot of this works
off of lead generation.
Lead generation gives
you the incentive
to game the system,
which is unfortunate.
So that's been a
bit of a problem.
I think also-- I don't actually
really have a good explanation.
I think for some reason this
started culturally in the UK
with smaller companies
about 10 years ago
and it hasn't
doesn't seem to have
caught on here in the same way.
And there are a lot
of inherent challenges
in trying to do comparisons for
10 different things at once.
Like the fact the
people generally
shop for any one of those only
once every couple of years.
But one way or another,
I think it's still
a model that ought to
be applicable here,
because this is actually
one and only one
of several sites in the UK
that have been operating
successfully.
Anyway somebody should
figure this out.
I think it's an
interesting challenge.
Next trend- we're seeing
a lot of use of open data
in an investment context, which
I think can be good for society
as well.
This is a British
company-- there's
a lot of work going
on in London-- that
is making open data available
about small to medium size
enterprises.
Private companies that have had
trouble attracting investment
because the investors
don't want to go
to all the trouble of
analyzing whether or not
they're a good risk.
These guys are providing
enough information
that they believe they
can get about $250 billion
more dollars invested
in these companies
by simply providing the
information that lets investors
invest with confidence.
So that's a good
thing for business.
But a lot of the
potential I think
is in what used to be called
corporate responsibility--
what's now being called
environmental social governance
measures, because we're seeing
more and more investors who
consider good sustainable
practices to be
a sign of good
corporate governance.
So for example, the
Carbon Disclosure Project
collects data on
carbon footprint
from most of the major
companies from Fortune
500 and other companies.
They represent
institutional investors
who collectively have about
$87 trillion to invest.
So we're seeing some real
interest from that community.
We're seeing the same kind
of thing being applied
to the consumer
field, particularly
by a company in San Francisco
called GoodGuide, which
it provides a lot of
information to consumers
about the environmental impact
of the products and services
they buy.
Much of this based on
EPA and other open data.
Companies are now becoming more
and more interested in this
because they want
to see if they have
a good profile the
consumers will like.
And then finally, the Securities
and Exchange Commission
has begun to demand that
companies that report to them
include information on
things like whether or not
they use conflict minerals,
which are minerals that
are mined under pretty horrible
conditions in the Republic
of Congo.
That kind of thing, which
happen under Dodd-Frank
could be the beginning of the
SEC demanding more and more
environmental social
governance measures.
If that were to happen, we
could see some real changes
in corporate practices.
So I think this is a case
where open data, because it's
of interest not only
to citizens, but also
to the investor community,
can have a lot of leverage
in improving corporate behavior.
We're seeing open data
shape reputation and brand
in some powerful ways.
Part of this is
public complaints
and what happens when you make
complaints about a company
public.
So these two people
founded a company
called PublikDemand, which
takes complaints from consumers,
amplifies them through
social media to an extent
that a company like
AT&T or United Airlines
has to immediately
pay attention.
And in many cases they've
gotten very rapid solutions
to problems that otherwise
would have gone back and forth
with customer
service for months.
Well this is a strategy that
regulatory agencies are also
following.
The Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau in particular
has made its complaint
database public.
And banks are now paying
much more attention
to customer complaints
and customer satisfaction
than they ever would have
because of this open data.
Both "Forbes" and
"American Banker"
have written about how this
is really changing the banking
industry, because they
have to listen collectively
to consumers whereas they could
ignore people one at a time.
The next stage of this, I think,
is analyzing social media.
Since we are now at this stage
of 2 billion tweets a week
which is-- I don't
know about you--
I find that somewhat terrifying.
But not only through the
kinds of reviews and comments
people do on Google, but
these other sites as well.
We're seeing a whole huge amount
of social media commentary
and you would think that if
you could actually figure out
how to analyze this and
do something with it,
you would have a very powerful
form of open data that
has huge business relevance.
Well one company that
is working on this
is reputation.com, which is in
the business of helping people
improve their online
reputations mostly by promoting
more positive and
genuinely positive
feelings about what
they have to say.
But there is a whole
other level of this--
of sentiment analysis--
which many of you
may be familiar with.
So I always like to
ask how many people
know who the woman
on the left is?
How many people know who
the guy on the right is?
OK, at least a couple generally
in every tech audience
more people
recognize Alan Turing
than recognize Jane Austen
but that's who they are.
And if Jane Austen and Alan
Turing had a love child,
it would be sentiment analysis.
Because sentiment
analysis essentially
is this technique of doing
text analysis to figure out
what people feel about
brands, celebrities,
TV shows, specific products,
specific services, et cetera.
There is an annual conference
now held in New York-- well,
I think it's usually
New York-- every March
where people get together
talk about this stuff.
It's a chapter in my book.
I've also done a
podcast with a guy named
Seth Grimes, who's
a guru in this area.
That's on my website.
It's absolutely fascinating.
It's not yet a
mature technology,
but ultimately you can
see where this is going.
This is going towards
treating all of social media
as an analyzable,
quantifiable form of open data
that can have a lot of
implications in a lot of areas.
Personal data is a
specific kind of open data
in that this is about making
data about my medical records
available to me, or
like Opower, my energy
usage available to me.
It doesn't really fit
the classic definition
of open data.
It's not like available
to everybody for free,
but it's a very important
part of the ecosystem.
Partly because opening data to
me is a different kind of thing
that me not being able
to access my own data.
And also because in many
applications of big open data,
having the ability to match
it up with personal data
is an important
part of the puzzle.
This is actually the diagram
from a report by the World
Economic Forum.
They've now done a
couple of reports
on unlocking the value
of personal data.
The basic idea that
people are talking about
is what if you could
establish a data vault.
So I'm seeing this as probably
a concept that many of you
thought about a lot.
It's been kicking
around for a while.
It may or may not be getting
to a point the applicability
or maturity.
There are companies
like reputation.com,
personal.com in DC, and others
that are looking at this.
But the basic idea
is, if you had
access to your personal data,
if you can hold it securely,
and if you could then release
it selectively to other people
or to marketers,
what would happen?
Well one model, which is being
called vendor relationship
marketing by Doc Searls who
talks about it in his book,
"The Intention
Economy," one model
is that instead of marketers
targeting you, you target them.
It is worth about $2,000
for a Mercedes Benz dealer
to get a qualified buyer on the
lot based on the probability
that they're going to buy a car.
So it might be worth a couple
dollars for that person
to find you if you wanted
to release demographic
or whatever kind
of information that
made you look like
a good customer
and actually pay
you to make a visit.
That's a kind of
simple form, but some
of the people
working in this area
think there's a lot
economic potential there.
I think it's still
hypothetical, but at least
points towards the
greater degree of consumer
control over how we
are all marketed to.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
there is potentially
tremendous public value
in sharing personal data.
This is this app PulsePoint,
which is essentially
if you are a person who knows
CPR, you tell them that.
If there's somebody who
is having cardiac arrest,
they then immediately
send a message
to everybody nearby
who knows CPR.
They can get to them faster
than an ambulance can.
They can potentially
save a life.
So this is the use
of personal data
that I'm not sure anybody
would have thought
of a couple years ago,
but it's the kind of thing
that when you start
thinking of personal data
as a form of open data on a
voluntary basis some really
interesting things can happen.
They talk about themselves as
enabling citizen superheroes
and I think that's
actually pretty accurate.
Open data and research-
this is another area where
I think we're going to see
potentially huge benefits.
We're seeing more and more
interest and more and more
pressure for particularly
biomedical, but potentially
other kinds of scientific
research to be more open.
Now a couple things
are happening here.
One is the open access
movement with which, of course,
Aaron Swartz was very
involved in promoting
and very tragically in the end.
But that's very much
about one state,
as in a published
journal, we shouldn't all
have to pay thousands of
dollars to get at that data
in order to get at that report.
And the federal
government recently
announced just a couple
weeks ago that about half
of all federally-funded
research will now
have to be made publicly
available for free
online within a year of
its publication in journal.
That's sort of after the fact.
What gets even
more interesting is
data sharing while the
work is in progress.
So a lot of this is coming
from patients and from funders.
Kathy Giusti was a corporate
CEO in her 30's when
she discovered she
had multiple myeloma.
She quickly discovered that
there was very little research
being done.
She started a foundation
to fund that research.
And a condition was if
you take their money,
you have to make your
data openly available
as you make new discoveries.
This is in many ways the model
that the Human Genome Project
worked on very successfully.
It's now being followed
in Alzheimer's research
and Parkinson's research
and in other ways as well.
It is potentially a
transformational change
in how we do science.
If the business models
are worked out and if
there's enough cooperation
from scientists
and from drug
companies and others
to really make this the norm.
We're also seeing a lot of
very successful experiments
in crowd-sourcing science.
One of the most famous was done
at University of Washington
a couple years ago.
They had been working
for a decade trying
to solve protein structure for
protein related to the AIDS
virus.
They decided to put
it on the site Foldit
and asked gamers to solve it.
Gamers solved it
within a couple weeks.
They published in "Nature"
and they thanked the gamers
publicly.
This was, I think, eye-opening
for a lot of people.
Another example, any of you
know Galaxy Zoo or Zooniverse?
This is one of the great
citizen science projects
and it's really a
model for many of them.
This thing got started in Oxford
because some poor PhD student
had to look at images of the
structure of spiral galaxies,
which apparently computers
cannot assess very well.
And he had hundreds of
thousands of these to look at.
He looked at 50,000
in a week and he
said there's got
to be a better way.
They decided that the better
way was posting these images
online, inviting just
ordinary people look at them.
They can do it with a
high degree of accuracy.
They've now taken on
other scientific projects,
like cancer cells
as you see here.
They have tapped
800,000 volunteers
to help them do
skilled human work
in the interest of science.
And then finally SkyTruth is
applying the same kind of thing
to the environment.
This is a nonprofit
in the Washington area
that is now using crowd sourcing
to look at things like maps
of areas of Pennsylvania
where fracking is going on
and look at signs that fracking
is damaging the environment.
So this becomes
environmental protection
through open data
from the satellites
and crowd sourcing
applied to that open data.
Data driven cities is a
huge movement right now.
Right at NYU we have the Center
for Urban Science and Progress,
which is doing a lot
of work in this area.
The idea is to put sensors
all over cities, to instrument
cities, to see what
can be learned,
to improve operations, public
health, emergency management,
all kinds of things.
You're also seeing a lot of
use of data for accountability
in cities like Chicago.
Palo Alto has been
a leader here.
And there are a couple
of interesting things
to come out of this.
One is applications
like NextBus,
which is now over the country,
where city traffic data can
be used to help you figure out
when your next bus is coming
so you're not waiting
endlessly in the rain.
To things like this
experiment in Washington
where they have actually
solicited public input
about how the different
government agencies are doing.
So they've actually been able
to grade government agencies
on the basis of both survey
data that they collect
and sentiment analysis
of what people
are saying on social media.
When they first did this,
four out of five agencies
got a c minus one got a c plus.
They were not very happy with
the mayor for doing this,
but they have gone
public with it.
It's a really
interesting feedback loop
and over time, the
grades have gone up.
So now the last
trend and this is
one where we're really
intensely focused at NYU--
is trying to figure out when you
look at all of this together,
what is open data worth?
And this is an
important question
because it is not a slam
dunk or particularly
easy to take data that has
traditionally been siloed
and open it to the public.
So there have been a
number of studies on this.
The most recent was
McKinsey study last October
that says that open data
is worth $3 trillion a year
worldwide.
That's by far the highest
estimate anybody has come up
with as you can see from some
of the other ones on the screen.
But generally the
estimates run pretty high.
So it's a very
interesting challenge
we all think there's
potential there,
but what we have done
at the GovLab at NYU,
is we've set out to do this
thing called the Open Data
500, which is about figuring
out exactly where the value is.
Beginning in the
business sector,
but ultimately wanting to
look at the nonprofit sector
as well.
We're looking at the
US based companies.
We have actually contacted
more than 500 of them.
We're in the process
of finalizing the list.
If this interests
you, I would urge
you to please go to
opendata500.com because we
are really seeking public
comment on everything
from individual companies
to our methodology
to whole goals of the study.
Or you can tweet to hashtag
#OD500 if you have suggestions
for us.
We have this now on a website
as a work in progress,
where you can filter
by state or by category
and see where some of these
open data companies are.
Not surprisingly the greatest
numbers are in California,
but I'm glad to say,
as a New Yorker,
that New York is not far behind.
And we're beginning to see
some interesting patterns here
that I think are really
going to be meaningful.
So one of those patterns, which
I'll show you in a second,
helps answer some of the open
questions about open data.
So having shown you
all these trends,
and shown you all
the stuff that's
happening that I talked
about my book and the website
and my other work, there's
still a lot we don't know.
And I would say there's three
major questions that where
now all looking to answer.
So the first one is, OK if
we think open data has value,
which sectors are
the most promising?
Well from the Open Data
500-- even though this
is preliminary, I can't stress
that enough because this is not
a final list, et
cetera-- but we're
starting to see
some hints of that.
So the first tier, the
company's the sectors that
have the most
companies in them are
what we're calling
data slash technology
and finance and investment.
Finance and investment
probably because there's
so much interest,
and because SEC data
and other kinds of business
data has been out there
for a long time and
is a very rich source.
Data technology because there
is a whole huge emerging
sector in helping
figure out how to take
really unwieldy government
data sets and turn them
into usable open data.
So this is companies like
Socrata, Junar, OpenGov here
in Palo Alto, or
nearby, and many others.
That their business is making
open data business-friendly.
And one of the
interesting questions
is whether this is
something that's
going to be around forever,
which I think it probably will,
as we were talking about
a little bit before.
Or how much this sector
may change as governments
get better at
releasing open data.
Next we have health
care-- which I
think is emerging--
transportation, energy,
and then the third tier,
where only about a couple
percent the companies we have
are in each of these areas.
This includes a number things.
Many of which are really quite
significant like education,
scientific research,
environment, food
and agriculture, the climate
corporation for example,
is somewhere in this tier.
So we just have a couple
of initial observations
and caveats about this.
One is that sectors that
don't have a lot of companies
in them, like weather
and agriculture,
may have a climate
corporation in there
or may have a very
significant company.
So simply number of
companies per sector
doesn't necessarily tell you
the importance of the sector,
but it does tell
you at least where
a lot of the
entrepreneurial activity is.
We still have to do more work
we are getting information
on the number of employees
per company, which
is going to be an
important metric.
We're trying to get information
on financial metrics
and as I said the data
technology category.
I was very interested
to see that so high up
and I think it says
something about the sorry
state of government data.
Which leads directly
to question number
two- how do we improve
the open data ecosystem?
Having worked in the federal
government for a while
and talked to people
a lot agencies,
I can tell you a lot of those
government data sets are
a mess and the people
who run them know it.
And they are trying to
fix it, but it's not
going to happen overnight.
So there are a couple
things that are happening.
On a city level, OpenGov, which
is a company right near here,
has developed what they like
to call kind of a Sim City
for actual cities.
So they have this thing you
can see in the upper right,
where they can take budget and
other city data from any city,
put on a platform
that makes it usable,
and that also makes a comparable
to other cities' data.
And they can then make town
meetings much more productive.
They can tell you why Palo Alto
has a certain rate a police
overtime and how that
compares to San Mateo
and they can learn things about
city governance from that.
So this is one of those data
slash technology companies
that's beginning to make
the data more useful.
Another one which is a
couple blocks from us at NYU
is called Enigma.
They won TechCrunch Disrupt
in New York last May.
And what was
significant about that
was, not just what they got
this nice large $50,000 check,
but that I think there
was a recognition of how
important data companies are.
Their whole thing is taking
really unwieldy government
federal data sets
and making them
usable on a common platform
and interoperable ways.
And they're getting
a ton of attention
right now because
this is something
that everybody who has ever
worked with federal data
has wanted.
And the reason for that is
that right now federal data
looks something like this.
For those of you who have seen
"Raiders of the Lost Ark."
The pathetic thing
about this is not only
the federal data is this bad,
but that this is the metaphor
that everybody in the federal
government who works with data
uses to describe the
state of federal data.
It is that bad and we know it.
There's good stuff
in there somewhere,
but good luck finding it.
A lot of the work going on in
government and in third parties
like Enigma and like OpenGov is
to make this stuff more useful.
And the open question is how
can we really make this work?
And this is an area
where I certainly
think certainly
Google has done a lot
and has a huge role to play.
I think also part
of this is going
to be what I'm calling
demand-driven data disclosure.
The way it's worked in the
past, government agencies
have largely released open
data when they've identified
data set they think
are of interest,
or where they're just
doing it to compare
to comply with the
government mandate.
One of the things we want to
get out of the Open Data 500
is to create a kind of round
table, where data users can
give much more ongoing
feedback to data holders
in the government agency.
We think this is going to really
improve the quality of data,
the availability of data,
and the ecosystem as a whole.
And then finally, how
can developing countries
use open data?
This is a huge question that
the World Bank among others
is putting a lot of effort into.
I'm going to be on
a panel for them
the next Wednesday
afternoon in DC.
And there's a
couple of areas here
one is fighting corruption.
This is the website that
has I think the best
name of any website I've seen
it is called ipaidabribe.com.
This is a website in
India, where you can go
and through crowd
sourcing report if you
had to pay bribe in a way that
makes corruption transparent
and ultimately
decreases corruption.
But we're also looking
to go beyond transparency
to economic development
and a lot of people
are asking whether developing
countries can use all the data
as a business resource
in the same way
that we're seeing in the US,
the UK, France and places
like that.
So one of my colleagues of the
World Bank, Prasanna Lal Dass,
recently did a
very good blog post
summarizing some of the
things that are needed.
As you can see, it's
going to take some work,
but the rewards may be great.
And I'm seeing a lot
of interest right now
in figuring out how to make that
work and can we make it work.
So that's the open
data universe at least
as I've come to see it through
the work I've done here.
I would recommend
you to a couple
of sources for more information.
One is at thegovlab.org,
where you can see our wiki,
subscribe to our digest.
You can also sign up outside
to get a digest subscription.
It comes out every week.
It's a curated collection
of material in this area.
There's opendatanow.com,
where I report
on this stuff on
a regular basis,
largely with interviews
with people in the field,
pod casts when I can
do them, hopefully
as a resource to the community.
And there is of course
this book now available,
which I see many of you have
already purchased thank you
and which I hope you find
useful in one way or another.
So we have a couple of
minutes for questions
and thank you very much.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
I have two questions.
one is, if you develop your
business using open data,
what are the caveats, what is
the license on all this data.
And the second question,
suppose I want some data.
Where would I find it?
For example I would
like to see some data
on education broken
down by gender.
Where would I go?
Where do I even start?
JOEL GURIN: OK so
two questions, one
is in terms of the
license use data.
It is only open data
if it's released
under an open license
that makes it usable
by anybody, and reusable,
and re-publishable.
So by definition,
that's pretty much built
in to the Open Data Policy,
at least of the US government,
more and more governments
recognize that.
In terms of where
you go, if you're
looking for federal data,
you should go to data.gov,
this is the central
repository of federal data.
It was originally built in a
way that I think a lot of people
found not as user-friendly,
as they want it.
They've just relaunched it.
It's much better.
It's getting better
all the time.
But that's where you would
find data like that segmented
by agency and by
area of interest.
As a start, in any case.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Obviously, you logically
focused on the US.
Is there any other nations
that you'd point to as best
in class who are really
leading the field in terms
of leveraging the
infrastructures developed
in their governments
or in their societies.
JOEL GURIN: Yes the UK is
really the other world leader
and in many ways
they're doing things
in a more advanced
way than the US.
For example, their
equivalent of data.gov
is all done with link
data is really very
beautifully and
very well designed.
So they are in some
ways ahead of us
in some ways learning from us.
They also have an institute
there called the Open Data
Institute that is funded
partly by the government
of by other sources
as well that's
doing a ton of work really
global leadership in this area.
Beyond that, we're
seeing a lot of interest
all over the world
on every continent.
And I think what's happening is
that different countries as I
mentioned there now 60 countries
or so in the Open Government
Partnership, which is committed
to these open government
principles, part of which
is open government data.
And it's rapidly emerging as
an international movement.
I think different
countries depending
on the stage of
development will figure out
what is the most important
and most appropriate
form of the data
for them to release.
AUDIENCE: So all
the applications
of open data that you
mentioned are all vertical.
They're trying to solve
a particular problem.
Do you see a need
or an opportunity
for more horizontal
plays of products
that could be usable by
many applications that
use open data?
JOEL GURIN: Well
I think probably
the best examples of those are
these data technology companies
like Enigma or OpenGov, because
what they're essentially
trying to do is to make data
of all kinds more usable.
And I think what
they're hoping to do
is to make possible the kinds
of mash-ups or interoperability
of data that can make a lot of
those more complex applications
possible.
Right now, at least if you're
working with US federal data,
it's very difficult.
We did a project at
the GovLab simply
to try to mash up EPA and
OSHA data about factories
and facilities that
both agencies regulate.
You would think
this was dead easy.
It's not.
I mean even on that
basic level, it
takes work to make this
stuff these data sets work
and play nicely together.
So companies that are
making that happen, I think,
are definitely taking that
kind of broad horizontal view
whether they're going
to be helpful to a lot
of other companies.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Do have any comments
about Aaron Swartz
who tried to liberate some
common government data
but got sued by the government.
JOEL GURIN: Yeah I write about
Aaron and that in my book.
I think everybody pretty
much recognizes now
that MIT was not a good path
there, to say the least.
And it gets into
some complexities,
but I think the short answer
is what Aaron was really
fighting for was open access
and access to material that
has already been published in a
way that the public can use it.
That's now just become
federal government policy
for about half as I
said of the research
that the federal
government funds
so I think there's a greater and
greater recognition that he was
right about that and that we
should start getting on board.
AUDIENCE: How do you think
about accuracy, or even just not
necessarily
accuracy, but knowing
what's in the data set, like
keeping track of the metadata,
like what's actually
being counted.
Who was excluded, who wasn't,
how data was collected,
and that kind of
information that
can change what the data means?
JOEL GURIN: Yeah that's
a great question.
I would say right now that's
very hard part of the Open Data
Policy is to actually
publicly release information
about the quality of data.
I think this is going to be
one of the parts of the policy
that federal agencies
absolutely hate the most.
But there are some really
interesting examples
of agencies facing
up to this problem
and dealing with it so
one great example is
USAID-- international
development--
knew that they had
lousy geospatial data
on the organizations they
were giving grants to.
They put on a hack-a-thon,
but a very careful one.
They found people who are
sort of geospatial hackers
in the Washington area.
They invited about
100 people in.
They said, we're going to give
you special access to our data.
We want you to fix it.
We'll give you all the weekend.
They were done in
about 15 or 16 hours.
So this idea of kind of
crowd-sourcing quality control
is one that a couple
of government agencies
have become interested in.
But simply knowing is very hard.
And that's one of
the reasons that I
think establishing
feedback loops-- really
good feedback loops between
data users and the agencies
that hold the data-- is going
to be critical next step.
So that we can ask those
questions government agencies
We can see what the response is.
And where there is a
really serious flaw
in a really important
data set, they
can prioritize that as something
that stakeholders need fixed.
AUDIENCE: And so you showed
a lot of great examples.
I was wondering if you
think that we can leverage
mobile in a specific way as
opposed to the desktop sites.
JOEL GURIN: Yes.
I tend to show desktops because
they look better on PowerPoint,
but absolutely most
of these things
that I showed either
are mobile apps
or could be mobile apps as well.
I think the one
caveat on mobile apps
is that we are a little bit risk
of app mania with open data.
There have been all
these hack-a-thons
of apps for this or apps
for that, which is great,
but I think there are probably
some limitations in what
is easy to do in that
mobile environment.
And there are some more
sophisticated things
that can be done if you, I
believe, look more broadly.
But definitely
pretty much anything
that I showed you has a mobile
application attached to it
FUMI YAMAZAKI: OK.
Thank you very much.
I think we're
running out of time
but Joel will be
staying here for us.
Thank you very much.
JOEL GURIN: Thanks
so much for coming.
And thank you for the
work you're all doing.